u.s president joe biden spoke for almost
two hours from the east room of the
white house given this was only his
second formal press conference reporters
had a lot of questions
hang on
his remarks included another warning to
president vladimir putin russia will
face severe penalties if it chooses to
invade ukraine my guess is he will move
in it's biden's most definitive
statement yet on putin's intentions but
his comments spark criticism when he
suggested a lesser response if russia
launches a small scale invasion
if it invades and it depends on what it
does it's one thing if it's a minor
incursion and then we end up having to
fight about what to do and not do etc
that forced the white house to issue a
clarification saying any invasion will
be met with a swift and severe response
biden spoke on the eve of the
anniversary of his first year in office
at times he was defensive for what many
see as foreign policy blunders like his
decision to withdraw u.s troops from
afghanistan i make no apologies for what
i did now am i do i feel badly
what's happening to
we as a consequence of the incompetence
of the taliban
yes i do
i feel badly about a whole range of
things around the world
that we can't solve every problem
on the issue of yemen biden says the u.s
is considering restoring its designation
of yemen's houthis as a terrorist group
following a cross-border strike this
week that killed three people in the
united arab emirates it's under
consideration and
ending the war in yemen takes the two
parties to be involved to do it
and it's going to be very difficult
domestically biden had promised to
eradicate covet 19
but with the pandemic entering his third
year he acknowledged he could have done
more to stop infections should we have
done more testing earlier yes
but we're doing more now
biden also pleaded for patience
promising he'll fulfill his pledge to
black voters by not abandoning voting
rights reform legislation i've had their
back i've had their back my entire
career
president biden's challenge is to prove
that his approval ratings have been
dropping with each month and as he marks
his first year in office voter
satisfaction is among the worst of his
presidency
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house